oh let's give it some breaking news now
a prominent Palestinian activist khada
Adnan has died in an Israeli prison
after 86 days on Hunger Strike Adnan was
a leading member of Islamic Jihad he was
arrested by Israeli forces near his home
in Janine in early February and has been
on hunger strike against his detention
without charges let's bring Anita
Ibrahim she's on the line from from
Ramallah in the occupied West Bank Nida
what more can you tell us about harder
Adnan and the events leading up to his
death
party he's a father of nine and spent a
total of eight years in Israeli prisons
now while this is not his first Congress
tribe we believe it's the sixth this is
the first time he was on hunger strike
four charges actually he announced his
hunger strike the first uh day he was
arrested in February and said that the
charges that he's been
um
mentions that
that charges that he's presented with do
not are not compatible since then he's
posted the hunger strike this was the
the 86th of his striking has found that
in his cell and his moved to the
hospital it's
weren't mentioning that coverage man
himself was the Pioneer who kind of
stunted the series of hunger strikes for
a Palestinian prisoners as individuals
so in 2012 he started a hunger strike
and he succeeded in ending his detention
without charging charging basically
leading the way for more Palestinian
prisoners to go on Hunger Strike when
there are when they're arrested without
charges now this time it was different
he was presented with a list of charges
but he said that they are not compatible
with the symptoms that he was presented
with now there has been a strike
announced in Janine and all of course
the occupied West Bank we know that
237 Palestinians have been killed or
died and has really confident since
1967. Anita just quickly um is his death
likely to lead to an escalation in
violence across the West Bank do you
think
well
Islamic Jihad party has said earlier
that if he dies during the hunger strike
it is going to be considered an
assassination and there has been a
strike announced the engineering and all
across the occupied with them but it's
hard to tell how that that is going to
be played out on the street it all
probably depends on Islamic Jihad and
what kind of a reaction they're going to
have after his death okay Anita Ibrahim
life was there in Ramallah in the
occupied West Bank Nida thank you